こんにちは
肇社長ですね
いつからでしたかで私
中古ソップで
とあるは人形
購入したですよねパッと見
すごく不気味だ人形でしたが
何故か私は
その人形に微力を感じましてついつい
買ってしまったわけですよ
ガー発です
こちらの人形です
[音楽]
コード人形を買ってから
約2ヶ月が経ちましたある部屋にずっと置かれていたんですが
その部屋の周りで
[音楽]
変なことが起きているんですよ
ぶっこわや本当の話ですそれも僕だけじゃなくてなんか僕だけだったらなんかくわ
うわぁやらせっぽいになると思うんですけども僕以外の方もねちょっと変な現象にあっ
たりしております
[音楽]
これをこれで公園けどね郊外クンもう一人すごいいろんな
現象にあっているみたいです舞いました
ほんと恋ネーションに変えまし
かんたんに
ルトっ
金縛りにあってい
けどこの右を置いているミラでん
いったら
体が動かなくなっていねぇー
ben はぱねぇはぁっはぁっはぁっ
ああああ上の方からのがこの
人形ボーイてる方かからの気配よ
感じつつから方のか乗って言う
かけて pc 話したさあムーン
女の短パンそこの中のかっすぐきと思う
それでは大丈夫だってそのあったねあんたさぁ的に年夏たくなかったんですけどあの
友達
その時ちょっとを聞けてその近くに塗ったんですけど
きたらさっきまで行ってから誰もいないはっはぁんってをかましてキュッキュッで
おおおっ友達にためこの中でドーンと聞こえた
だからさっきも聞こえた聞こえたっ
を待ってまずで強い助けてからついて強いためにこの話の続きなんですけどそう後メカ
のしまってセグ骨変にきてまた寝たんですけどちょっと信じてなくて若干はふざけん
じゃねーぞとって僕が次
その話針にあった部屋の近く寝たんですよ
そしたら今度僕が金縛りにあってしまいましたそれぞれ月ですなんかね多いらの時は
なんか人形からの金縛りというかなんか純正に金縛りにあっているか誰普通に動けねぇ
みたいな感じだったんであんまりなんか人形から来たっていう感じです何かわかんない
ちょっ多分深く考えすぎてなかったのかもしれんねわかんないけどとりあえずでカレー
型押し場であってお金も人がいたんですけどその人が
はこの日9型部屋から音を聞いたと通ってというわけでですねちょっとあの子の尿が
原因かはわからないんですけどもこの人形があった部屋で明らかにちょっと過ぎな現象
が僕だけじゃなくていろんな人たちがあって
おります
[音楽]
動画に取れていないこんな議論だこのバカル生き延びてるなんかわかんないですこの
人形でんかどうかもわかんないしか僕らの思い込みかもしれないしその辺がちょっと
わからないので今回の動画ではもう一度そのいろいろの減少が大変にことに気を戻して
奴は降ってきちゃっただけバナーファン
もう一度この人形その辺に戻すて有馬から彼と僕でちょっとでるんで寝てるところ
ちょっと動画に撮ってみて
が起きないか確かめてみようと思います本当に何かあったらちゃんと動画で何かあると
思うので確かめてみようと思いますで俺のかあさん曰く悪い奴じゃないんですよこの子
ってこの子学
入る前からあの家で何か怪しいデー気があるみたいなからちょい将生とかも出てたんで
ひょっとしたら守ってくれてたらかもしれないです
わからない結構最近の話なんて明らかに何かが起きているような気がするのでをしかめ
てみようと思いますレッツ gree
以下もいっぱいというわけでこの部屋が倍の部屋になっております以上ですね人形あっ
た場所彼らへんかな
ここらへんにず遠いだったんですようん着火入れる
これはもうすでに始まってますないやもうほんとこの人形のせいじゃないと思うよねな
母ちゃんよく当たるからむしろこいつ良い奴先生があるんですけども
もうこのやゆるだけで鳥肌が本土と
同じぐらいちょっと怖いですね前までここで動画を撮ってたんですけど最近ここも編集
ベアとして選んだ空気を利用して出張して編集する今編集やにしておりますさあこれ
から後輩の一人で寝る付のこの謎の編
何が起きるのでしょうか
ここはやばい地と本当に緊張してきたそれでは
ねます
おやすみなさい声恋チュン
おやすみ
[拍手]
[音楽]
あー怖い怖い言っこうやっふううううう
叫んだ
ん
[音楽]
あん
おわかりいただけただろうか
という小さな音の後に
カヅカっ
女性のむっ
ちくしょう感じた女性の植木声のような声が聞こえている
うーん
ふーんん
うん
人形伝特に何か起きたわけでもなく
我々2人が
金縛りにあうこともなかったかなぁ
と思っ
夏の物音は夜中自分が見続けていただ
[音楽]
そして夜中に謎のインター
いいと思っ
tari tari が来たのだろうか
そして
ん
おっ
[音楽]
好香
[拍手]
うん
masa
いきましょう
いっ
4日